This kid,
he's a basketball phenom.
But they'll be asking,
can this grown man
play at the next level?
We're all trying to understand
each other using the game
of basketball as the backdrop.
[YELLING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
(SINGING) Why my
opposition always mad at me.
Go get you a crowd
if you as bad as me.
I'm a kid.
The kids got a lot bigger.
They're a lot bigger, a
lot faster, a lot stronger.
A lot of new stories.
There's a lot of new journeys.
Same old Jace, always
trying to control things.
We see them in their
senior year, where
they're really
feeling this urgency
to just figure out their life.
You taught me
to respect women.
I taught you to
use common sense.
You're going to see Jace
coming into his own as a man.
Plus, I got a car.
[BRAKES SCREECHING]
(SINGING)
Everything will win.
I am the athletic director
at Cedar Cove Academy.
Emery comes in and just
challenges Ike's perspective,
challenges all of
our characters.
Is democracy a
destination or a journey?
Jace is
acting as a grown man,
so Jenna is trying to find
her peace in the storm.
Oh.
You ain't making any babies.
(SINGING)
When you're on the top,
they're going to blame the sins.
Well, the blessings going to
start when the hate it ends.
It's covering the politics
of what's happening--
You think winning
state attracts donations?
What do you think winning a high
school national championship
would attract?
--and then also between
fathers and mothers
and daughters and sons.
Since you've been
out of jail, I'm happy.
I can't lose you again.
I'm not through miss if she's
still sleeping in our bed.
It's not my fault
we made a cuteass baby
that thinks I'm cozy.
VOICEOVER: (SINGING) Put me in
position when I pay the price.
Peter Pan dreams come from
fighting through the sacrifice.
This season
is your last hurrah.
So let's go out with a bang.
(SINGING)
Everybody's so sinful now.
But you ain't got no know-how.
The
basketball's authentic.
You see somebody
dunking, they're dunking.
They're not jumping
off of a trampoline.
(SINGING)
Everything will win.
One, two, three.
[YELLS]
(SINGING)
We never quit.
We never fail.
I want you to remember this.
Winners are made on the court.
Champions are made
off the court.
The issues that they deal
with are just real adult issues.
You got D-1, college, all
this shit going for you.
We can't be getting caught
up in all dumb shit.
This season, it's really
important to know that even
when things get
hard, to not give up.
I'm told you might
have knowledge
about who attacked Joe Ward.
I never thought I'd be going
through this with you, Jace.
Not like this.
We've got new characters.
We've got new players as well.
For me, it was probably
one of the most special jobs
I've had my career.
You guys have a hell of
a season coming at you.
Get ready.
(SINGING) I'm a king.
Oh oh oh oh oh.
King.
But I'm a king.